[SQUEAKING]
[RUSTLING]
[CLICKING]
DAVID SONTAG: So
today's lecture is
going to continue on
the lecture that you
saw on Tuesday, which
was introducing you
to causal inference.
So the causal inference
setting, which
we're studying in this course,
is a really simplistic one
from a causal
graphs perspective.
There are three sets of
variables of interest--
everything you know about an
individual or patient, which
we're calling x over here;
and intervention or action--
which for today's
lecture, we're going
to suppose that it's either 0
or 1, so a binary intervention.
You either take it or don't--
and an outcome y.
And what makes this
problem of understanding
the impact of the intervention
on the outcome challenging
is that we have to
make that inference
from observational data, where
we don't have the ability--
at least not in
medicine, we typically
don't have the ability to
make active interventions.
And the goal of what we will
be discussing in this course
is about how to take
data that was collected
from a practice of medicine
where actions or interventions
were taken, and then use
that to infer something
about the causal effect.
And obviously, there are also
randomized control trials
where one intentionally
does randomize,
but the focus of
today's lecture is
going to be using observational
data, or ready collected data,
to try to make
these conclusions.
So we introduced the language of
potential outcomes on Tuesday.
Potential outcomes is the
mathematical framework
for trying to answer
these questions.
Then with that definition
of potential outcomes,
we can define the conditional
average treatment effect,
which is the difference
between Y1 and Y0
for the individual Xi.
So you'll notice here
that I have patients,
so treating the
potential outcome
as a random variable
in case there
might be some stochasticity.
So sometimes, maybe if you were
to give someone a treatment,
it works, and
sometimes it doesn't.
So that's what the
expectation is accounting for.
Any questions before I move on?
So with respect
to this definition
of conditional average
treatment effect, then
you could ask, well, what
would happen in aggregate
for the population?
And you can compute
that by taking
the average of the conditional
average treatment effect
over all of the individuals.
So that's just this expectation
with respect to, now, p of x.
Now, critically, this
distribution, p of x, you
should think about as the
distribution of everyone
that exists in your data.
So some of those individuals
might have received
treatment 1 in the past.
Some of them might have
received treatment 0.
But when we ask this question
about average treatment effect,
we're asking, for both of
those populations, what
would have been the effect--
what would have been the
difference about [INAUDIBLE]
they received treatment 1 minus
had they received treatment 0?
Now, I wanted to
take this opportunity
to start thinking a little
bit bigger picture about how
causal inference can be
important in a variety
of societal
questions, and so I'd
like to now spend just a
couple of minutes thinking
with you about what some
causal questions might
be that we urgently need to
answer about the COVID-19
pandemic.
And as you try to think
through these questions,
I want you to have this
causal graph in mind.
So there is the
general population.
There is some action
that you want to perform,
and the whole notion
of causal inferences
assessing the effective action
on some outcome of interest.
So in trying to give
the answer to my--
various answers to
my questions of what
are some causal inference
questions of relevance
to the current
pandemic, I want you
to try to frame your answers in
terms of these Xs, Ts, and Ys.
It's also, obviously,
very hard to answer
using the types of techniques
that we will be discussing
in this course, and partly
because the techniques that I'm
focusing on are very much
data driven techniques.
That said, the general framework
that I've introduced on Tuesday
for covariate adjustment
of, come up with a model
and use that model
to make a prediction,
and the assumptions that
underlie that in terms of,
well, where's that model
coming from, if you're fitting
the parameters from data, having
to have common support in order
to be able to have any trust
in the downstream conclusions.
Those underlying assumptions
and the general premises
will still hold,
but here, obviously,
when it comes to something
like social distancing,
they're complicated
network effects.
And so whereas up
until now, we've
been making the assumption
of what was called SUTVA--
it was a assumption that I
probably didn't even talk about
in Tuesday's lecture.
But intuitively, what
the SUTVA assumption says
is that each of your
training examples
are independent of each other.
And that might make sense
when you think about,
give a patient a
medication or not,
but it certainly
doesn't make sense
when you think about social
distancing type measures,
where if some people
social distance,
but other people don't,
it has obviously a very
different impact on society.
So one needs a different
class of models
to try to think about
that, which have
to relax that SUTVA assumption.
So those were all really
good answers to my question,
and in some sense, now--
so there's the
epidemiological type questions
that we last spoke about.
But the first few set
of questions about,
really, how does one treat
patients who have COVID
are the types of questions
that only now we can really
start to answer
now, unfortunately,
because we're starting to get
a lot of data in the United
States and internationally.
And so for example, my own
personal research group,
we're starting to
really scale up
our research on these
types of questions.
Now, one very simplified
example that I
wanted to give of how a causal
inference lens can be useful
here is by trying to
understand case fatality rates.
So for example, in
Italy, it was reported
that 4.3% of individuals
who had this condition
passed away,
whereas in China, it
was reported that 2.3%
of individuals who
had this condition passed away.
Now, you might ask, based
on just those two numbers,
is something
different about China?
For example, might
it be that the way
that COVID is being managed in
China is better than in Italy?
You might also wonder if
the strain of the disease
might be different
between China and Italy?
So perhaps there were some
mutations since it left Wuhan.
But if you dig a
little bit deeper,
you see that, if you plot case
fatality rates by age group,
you get this plot that
I'm showing over here.
And you see that if
you compare Italy,
which is the orange, to
China, which is blue, now
stratified by age range, you
see that for every single age
range, the percentage
of deaths is lower
in Italy than in
China, which would
seem to be a contradiction
with what we saw--
with the aggregate
numbers, where
we see that the case
fatality rate in Italy
is higher than in China.
And so the reason why this can
happen has to do with the fact
that the populations
are very different.
And by the way, this
paradox goes by the name
of Simpson's paradox.
So if you dig a bit
deeper, you see then
that, if you're
to look at, well,
what is the distribution of
individuals in China and Italy
that have been
reported to have COVID,
you see that, in Italy,
it's much more highly
weighted towards
these older ages.
And if you then combine that
with the total number of cases,
you get you get to
these discrepancies,
so it now fully explains
these two numbers
and the plot that you see.
Now if we're to try to think
about this a bit more formally,
we would try to
formalize it in terms
of following causal graph.
And so here, we have the
same notions of X, T, and Y,
where X is the age
of an individual who
has been diagnosed with COVID.
T is now country, so we're going
to think about the intervention
here as transporting
ourselves from China to Italy,
so thinking about changing
the environment altogether.
And Y is the outcome on
an individual level basis.
And so the formal
question that one
might want to ask is about
a causal impact of changing
the country on the outcome Y.
Now, for this particular
causal question,
this causal graph that I'm
drawing here is the wrong one,
and in fact, the right
causal graph probably
has an edge that
goes from T to X.
In particular, the distribution
of individuals in the country
is obviously a function
of the country,
not the other way around.
But despite the
fact that there is
that difference
in directionality,
all of the techniques that
we've been teaching you
in this course are still
applicable for trying
to ask a causal question about
the impact of intervening
on a country, and that's
really because, in some sense,
these two distributions,
at an observational level,
are equivalent.
And if you want to dig a little
bit deeper into this example--
and I want to stress this is
just for educational purposes.
Don't read anything
into these numbers--
I would go to this Colab
notebook after the course.
So all of this was
just a little bit
of set up to help frame where
causal inference shows up
and some things that
we've been thinking
and really very worried and
stressed about ourselves
personally recently.
And I want to now shift
gears to starting to get back
to the course material,
and in particular, I
want to start today's
more theoretical parts
of the lectures by returning
to covariate adjustment,
which we ended on and Tuesday.
In covariate adjustment, one--
we'll use a machine learning
approach to learn some model,
which I'll call F. So you could
imagine a black box machine
learning algorithm, which
takes as input both X and T.
So X are your covariates of
the individual that are going
to receive the treatment, and
T is that treatment decision,
which for today's lecture, you
can just assume is binary 01,
and uses those together now
to predict the outcome Y.
Now, what we showed on Tuesday
was that, under ignorability,
where ignorability,
remember, was
the assumption of no
hitting confounding,
then the conditional
average treatment effect
could be defined as
just a difference--
could be could be computed
as the expectation of Y1
now conditioned on
T equals 1, so this
is the piece that
I've added in here,
and minus the expectation of Y0
now conditioned on T equal 0.
And it's that conditioning
which is really important,
because that's what enables you
to estimate Y1 from data where
treatment 1 was observed,
whereas you never
get to observe Y1 in data when
treatment 0 was performed.
So we have this formula, and
after fitting that model F,
one could then use it
to try to estimate CATE
by just taking that
learned function,
plugging in the number 1
for the treatment variable
in order to get your
estimate of this expectation,
and then plugging in the number
0 for the treatment variable
when you want to get your
estimate of this expectation.
Taking the difference
between those
then gives you your estimate
of the conditional average
treatment effect.
So that's the approach, and what
we didn't talk about so much
was the modeling choices of what
should your function class be.
So this is going to turn
out to be really important,
and really, the punchline
of the next several slides
is going to be a major
difference in philosophy
between machine
learning and statistics,
and between prediction
and causal inference.
So let's now consider the
following simple model, where
I'm going to assume that the
ground truth in the real world
has that the potential outcome
YT of X, where T, again
is the treatment, is equal
to some simple linear model
involving the covariates
X and the treatments
T, the treatment T. So in
this very simple setting,
I'm going to assume that we
just have a single feature
or covariate for the
individual, which is there age.
I'm going to assume
that this model doesn't
have any terms with an
interaction between X and T,
so it's fully linear in X and T.
So this is an assumption about
the true potential outcomes,
and what we'll do over
the next couple of slides
is think about what would happen
if you now modeled Y of T,
so modeling it with
some function F, where
F was, let's say, a linear
function versus a nonlinear
function, if F took this
form or a different form.
And by the way,
I'm going to assume
that the noise here,
epsilon t, can be arbitrary,
but that it has 0 mean.
So let's get started by
trying to estimate what
the true CATE is, or
Conditional Average Treatment
Effect, for this
potential outcome model.
Well, just by
definition, the CATE
is the expectation
of Y1 minus Y0.
We're going to
take this formula,
and we're going to plug it
in for the first term using
T equals 1, and that's why
you get this term over here
with gamma.
And the gamma is because,
again, T is equal to 1.
We're also going to
take this, and we're
going to plug it in for,
now, this term over here,
where T is equal to 0.
And when T is equal to 0, then
the gamma term just disappears,
and so you just get
beta X plus epsilon 0.
So all I've done so far
is plug in the Y1 and Y0
according to the assumed form,
but notice now that there's
some terms that cancel
out-- in particular,
the beta X term over
here cancels out
with a beta X term over here.
And because epsilon 1 has a
0 mean, and epsilon 0 also
has a 0 mean.
The only thing left
is that gamma term,
and expectation of a constant's
obviously that constant.
And so what we
conclude from this
is that the CATE value is gamma.
Now, the average
treatment effect,
which is the average of
CATE over all individuals X,
will then also be
gamma, obviously.
So we've done something
pretty interesting here.
We've started from
the assumption
that the true potential
outcome model is linear,
and what we concluded is that
the average treatment effect is
precisely the coefficient
of the treatment
variable in this linear model.
So what that means is
that, if what you're
interested in is
causal inference,
and suppose that we
were lucky enough
to know that the true
model were linear,
and so we attempted to fit some
function F, which had precisely
the same form, we get some
beta hats and some gamma hats
out from the learning
algorithm, all we need to do
is look at that
gamma hat in order
to conclude something about
the average treatment effect.
No need to do this
complicated thing of plugging
in to estimate CATEs.
And again, the reason it's
such a trivial conclusion
is because of our
assumption of linearity.
Now, what that also
means is that, if you
have errors in
learning-- in particular,
suppose, for example, that
you are estimating your gamma
hat wrongly, then
that means you're also
going to be getting
wrong your estimates
of your conditional and
average treatment effects.
There's a question here,
which I was lucky enough
to see, that says, what
does gamma represent
in terms of the medication?
Thank you for that question.
So gamma is--
literally speaking,
gamma tells you the conditional
average treatment effect,
meaning if you were to give
the treatment versus not
giving the treatment, how
that affects the outcome.
Think about the outcome
of interest being
the patient's blood
pressure, there
being potential confounding
factor of the patient's age,
and T being one of two different
blood pressure measurements.
If gamma is positive,
then it means
that treatment 1 is more--
treatment 1 increases the
patient's blood pressure
relative to treatment 0.
And if gamma is
negative, it means
that treatment 1 decreases
the patient's blood pressure
relative to treatment 0.
So in machine learning--
oh, sorry, there's another chat.
Thank you, good.
So in machine learning, I
typically tell my students,
don't attempt to interpret
your coefficient.
At least, don't
interpret them too much.
Don't put too much
weight into them,
and that's because,
when you're learning
very high dimensional
models, there
can be a lot of redundancy
between your features.
But when you talk
to statisticians,
often they pay really
close attention
to their coefficients,
and they try
to interpret those coefficients
often with the causal lens.
And when I first got
started in this field,
I couldn't understand why
are they paying attention
to those coefficients so much?
Why are they coming up with
these causal hypotheses based
on which coefficients
are positive
and which are the negative?
And this is the answer.
It really comes down
to an interpretation
of the prediction
problem in terms
of the feature of
relevance being
a treatment, that treatment
being linear with respect
to the potential
outcome, and then
looking at the coefficient
of the treatment
as telling you something
about the average treatment
effect of that
intervention or treatment.
Moreover, that also tells us
why it's often very important
to look at confidence intervals,
so one might want to know,
we have some small data set, we
get some estimate of gamma hat,
but what if you had
a different data set?
So what happens if you had a
new sample of 100 data points?
How would your estimated
gamma hat vary?
And so you might be
interested, for example,
in confidence intervals, like
a 95% confident interval that
says that gamma hat is
between, let's say, 1
and, let's say maybe, 0.5
with probability 0.95.
That'll be an example
of a confidence
interval around gamma hat.
And such a confidence
interval then
gives you confidence--
a confidence interval
around the coefficients,
then gives you
confidence intervals around
the average treatment
effect via this analysis.
So the second
observation is what
happens if the true
model isn't linear,
but we hadn't realized
that as a modeler,
and we had just assumed that,
well, the linear model's
probably good enough?
And maybe even, the linear model
gets pretty good prediction
performance?
Well, let's look at the
extreme example of this.
Let's now assume that the
true data generating process,
instead of being just
beta X plus gamma T,
we're going to add in now a new
term, delta times X squared.
Now, this is the
most naive extension
of the original
linear model that you
could imagine, because I'm not
even adding any interaction
terms like 10 times XT.
So no interaction
terms involving
treatment and covariate.
Treatment is still--
the potential outcome
is still linear in treatment.
We're just adding a
single nonlinear term
involving one of the features.
Now, if you compute
the average treatment
effect via the same
analysis we did
before, you'll again find that
our treatment effect is gamma.
Let's suppose now
that we hadn't known
that there was that delta
X squared term in there,
and we hypothesized that the
potential outcome was given
to you by this linear
model involving X and T.
And I'm going to use Y
hat to denote that that's
going to be the function family
that we're going to be fitting.
So we now fit that
beta hat in gamma hat,
and if you had infinite data
drawn from this true generating
process, which is, again,
unknown, what one can show
is that the gamma hat
that you would estimate
using any reasonable estimator,
like a least squared estimator,
is actually equal to
gamma, the true ATE value,
plus delta times this term.
And notice that this term does
not depend on beta or gamma.
What this means is,
depending on delta,
your gamma hat could be
made arbitrarily large
or arbitrarily small.
So for example, if
delta is very large,
gamma hat might
become positive when
gamma might have been negative.
And so your conclusions about
the average treatment effect
could be completely wrong,
and this should scare you.
This is the thing which makes
using covariate adjustments so
dangerous, which
is that if you're
making the wrong assumptions
about the true potential
outcomes, you could get
very, very wrong conclusions.
So because of
that, one typically
wants to live in
a world where you
don't have to make many
assumptions about the form,
so that you could try to fit
the data as well as possible.
So here, you see that there
is this nonlinear term.
Well, obviously, if you had
used some nonlinear modeling
algorithm, like a neural network
or maybe a random forest,
then it would have the potential
to fix that nonlinear function,
and then maybe we wouldn't
get caught in this same trap.
And there are a variety of
machine learning algorithms
that have been applied to
causal inference, everything
from random forests and
Bayesian additive regression
trees to algorithms
like Gaussian processes
and deep neural networks.
I'll just briefly
highlight the last two.
So Gaussian processes
are very often
used to model continuous
valued potential outcomes,
and there are a couple of ways
in which they can be done.
So for example,
one class of models
might treat Y1 and Y0 as two
separate Gaussian processes
and fit those to the data.
A different approach,
shown on the right here,
would be to treat T as
an additional covariate,
so now you have X and
T as your features
and fit a Gaussian process
for that joint model.
When it comes to
neural networks,
neural networks had been used
in causal inference going back
about 20, 30 years, but really
started catching on a few years
ago with a paper that
I wrote in my group
as being one of
the earliest papers
from this recent generation
of using neural networks
for causal inference.
And one of the things that we
found to work very effectively
is to use a joint model for
predicting the causal effect,
so we're going to be
learning a model that takes--
an F that takes, as input,
X and T and has to predict
Y. And the advantage
of that is that it's
going to allow us to share
parameters across your T
equals 1 and T equals 0 samples.
But rather than
feeding in X and T
in your first layer of
your neural network,
we're only going to feed
in X in the initial layer
of the neural network,
and we're going
to learn a shared
representation, which
is going to be used
for both predicting
T equals 0 and T equals 1.
And then for predicting
when T is equal to 0,
we use a different head
from predicting T equals 1.
So F0 is a function that
concatenates these shared
layers with several
new layers used
to predict for when
T is equal to 0
and same analogously for 1.
And we found that architecture
worked substantially better
than the naive
architectures when
doing causal inference on
several different benchmark
data sets.
Now, the last thing
I want to talk about
for covariate
adjustment, before I
move on to a new
set of techniques,
is a method called
matching, that
is intuitively very pleasing.
It's a very-- would seem to
be a really natural approach
to do causal inference,
and at first glance,
may look like it has nothing
to do with covariate adjustment
technique.
What I'll do now is I'm
going to first introduce you
to the matching
technique, and then I
will show you that it
actually is precisely
identical to
covariate adjustment
with a particular
assumption of what
the functional family for F is.
So not Gaussian processes,
not deep neural networks,
but it'll be something else.
So before I get into
that, what is matching as
a technique for
causal inference?
Well, the key idea
of matching is
to use each
individual's twin to try
to get some intuition about what
their potential outcome might
have been?
So I created these
slides a few years ago
when President
Obama was in office,
and you might imagine this
is the actual President
Obama who did go to law school.
And you might imagine who might
have been that other president?
What President Obama
have been like had he not
gone to law school, but let's
say, gone to business school?
So if you can now imagine trying
to find, in your data set,
someone else who looks
just like Barack Obama,
but who, instead of
going to law school,
went to business school,
and then you would then
ask the following question.
For example, would
this individual
have gone on to
become president had
he gone to law school versus
had he gone to business school?
If you find someone
else who's just
like Barack Obama who went to
business school, look to see
did that person become
president eventually,
that would in essence give
you that counterfactual.
Obviously, this is
a contrived example
because you would never get
the sample size to see that.
So that's the general idea,
and now, I'll show it to you
in a picture.
So here now, we have to
covariates or features--
a patient's age and their
Charleson comorbidity index.
This is some measure
of how many--
what types of conditions
or comorbidities
the patient might have.
Do they have diabetes, do they
have hypertension, and so on?
And notably, what
I'm not showing
you here is the
outcome Y. All I'm
showing you are the
original data points
and what treatment
did they receive.
So blue are the individuals who
received the control treatment,
or T equals 0, and red
are the individuals
who received treatment 1.
So you can imagine trying
to find nearest neighbors.
For example, the
nearest neighbor
to this data point over here
is this blue point over here,
and so if you wanted to
know, well, what we observed,
some Y1, for this individual,
we observed some Y0
for this individual.
And if you wanted
to know, well, what
would have happened
to this individual
if they had received treatment
0 instead of treatment 1,
well, you could
just look at what
happened to this
blue point and say,
that's what would have
happened to this red point,
because they're very
close to each other.
Any questions
about what matching
would do before I
define it formally?
Here, I'll-- yeah,
good, one question.
What happens if the nearest
neighbor is extremely far away?
That's a great question.
So you can imagine that you have
one red data point over here
and no blue data points nearby.
The matching approach
wouldn't work very well.
So this data point,
the nearest neighbor,
is this blue point over here,
which intuitively, is very far
from this red point.
And so if we were to estimate
this red point's counterfactual
using that blue point,
we're likely to get
a very bad estimate,
and in fact, that
is going to be one of the
challenges of matching
based approaches.
It's going to work really well
in a high dimensional setting
where you can imagine--
sorry, in a large--
it's going to work very well in
a large sample setting, where
you can hope that you're likely
to observe a counterfactual
for every individual.
And it won't work well you
have very limited data,
and of course, all
this is going to be
subject to the assumption
of common support.
So one question's
about how does that
translate into high dimensions?
The short answer--
not very well.
We'll get back to
that in a moment.
Can a single data point
appear in multiple matchings?
Yes, and I will define, in
just a moment, how and why.
It won't be a strict matching.
Are we trying to
find a counterfactual
for each treated observation,
or one for each control
observation?
I'll answer that
in just a second.
And finally, is it common
for medical data sets
to find such matching pairs?
I'm going to reinterpret
that question as saying,
is this technique used
often in medicine?
And the answer
is, yes, it's used
all the time in clinical
research despite the fact
that bio statisticians,
for quite a few years now,
have been trying to argue
that folks should not
use this technique for
reasons that you see shortly.
So it's widely used.
It's very intuitive, which
is why I'm teaching it.
And it's going to fit into
a very general framework,
as you'll see in just a
moment, which I'll give you
the natural solution
for the problems
that I'm going to raise.
So moving on, and
then I'll return
to any remaining questions.
So here, I'll define one way of
doing counterfactual inference
using matching, and it's
going to start, of course,
by assuming that we
have some distance
metric d between individuals.
Then we're going to say,
for each individual i,
let's let j of i be the
other individual j, obviously
different from i, who is closest
to i, but critically, closest
but has a different treatment.
So where Ti is different
from Tj, and again,
I'm assuming binary,
so Tj is either 0 or 1.
With that definition
then, we're going
to define our estimate of the
conditional average treatment
effect for an individual is
whatever their actual observed
outcome was.
This, I'm going to give
for an individual that
actually received treatment 1,
so it's Y1, and the reason--
it's Yi minus the imputed
counterfactual corresponding
to T is equal to 0.
And the way we get that
computed counterfactual
is by trying to find
that nearest neighbor who
received treatment 0
instead of treatment 1
and looking at their Y.
Analogously, if T is
equal to 0, then we're
going to use the
observed Yi, now
over here instead of over there
because it corresponds to Y0.
And where we need to impute Y1--
capital Y1, potential
outcome Y1--
we're going to use the observed
outcome from the nearest
neighbor of individual i who
received treatment 1 instead
of 0.
So this, mathematically, is what
I mean by our matching based
estimator, and this
also should answer
one of the questions which
was raised, which is,
do you really need
to have it matching,
or could a data point be matched
to multiple other data points?
And indeed, here, you see the
answer to that last question
is yes, because you could have
a setting where, for example,
there are two red points here.
And I can't draw
blue, but I'll just
use a square for what I
would have drawn as blue.
And then everything
else very far away,
and for both of
these red points,
this blue point is
the closest neighbor.
So both of the counterfactual
estimates for these two points
would be using the
same blue point,
so that's the answer
to that question.
Now, I'm just going to
rewrite this in a little bit
more convenient form.
So I'll take this
formula, shown over here,
and you can rewrite
that as Yi minus Yji,
but you have to flip
the sign depending
on whether Ti is
equal to 1 or 0,
and so that's what this
term is going to do.
If Ti is equal to 1,
then this evaluates to 1.
If Ti is equal to 0, this
evaluates to minus 1.
Flips the sign.
So now that we have
the definition of CATE,
we can now easily estimate
the average treatment effect
by just averaging these CATEs
over all of the individuals
in your data set.
So this is now the
definition of how
to do one nearest
neighbor matching.
Any questions?
So one question is, do we ever
use the metric d to weight
how much we would, quote,
unquote, "trust" the matching?
That's a good question.
So what Hannah's
asking is, what happens
if you have, for example,
very many nearest
neighbors, or
analogously, what happens
if you have some
nearest neighbors that
are really close, some
that are really far?
You might imagine trying to
weight your nearest neighbors
by the distance
from the data point,
and you could imagine
even doing that--
you can even imagine coming
up with an estimator, which
might discount certain data
points if they don't have
nearest neighbors
near them at all
by the corresponding
weighting factor.
Yes, that's a good idea.
Yes, you can come up with
a consistent estimator
of the average treatment
effect through such an idea.
There are probably a few
hundred papers written about it,
and that's all I
have to say about it.
So there's lots of variants
of this, and they all end
up having the same
theoretical justification
that I'm about to give
in the next slide.
So one of the
advantages of matching
is that you get some
interpretability.
So if I was to ask
you, well, what's
the reason why you tell
me that this treatment is
going to work for John?
Well, someone can respond--
well, I used this
technique, and I
found that the nearest
neighbor to John was Anna.
And Anna took this other
treatment from John,
and this is what
happened for Anna.
And that's why I
conjecture that, for John,
the difference between
Y1 and Y0 is as follows.
And so then, that
can be criticized.
So for example, a clinician
who has some domain expert,
can look at Anna, look at John,
and say, oh, wait a second,
these two individuals are really
different from one another.
Let's say the
treatment, for example,
had to do with something
which was gender specific.
Comparing two individuals
which are of different genders
are obviously not going to
be comparable to one other,
and so then the
domain expert would
be able to reject that
conclusion and say,
nuh-uh, I don't trust
any of these statistics.
Go back to the drawing board.
And so type of interpretability
is very attractive.
The second aspect of this,
which is very attractive
is that it's a
non-parametric method,
non-parametric in the same
way that neural networks
or random forest
are non-parametric.
So this does not rely
on any strong assumption
about the parametric form
of the potential outcomes.
On the other hand,
this approach is
very reliant on the
underlying metric.
If your distance function
is a poor distance function,
then it's going to
give poor results.
And moreover, it could
be very much misled
by features that don't
affect the outcome, which
is not necessarily a
property that we want.
Now, here's that final slide
that makes the connection.
Matching is equivalent
to covariate adjustment.
It's exactly the same.
It's an instantiation
of covariate adjustment
with a particular
functional family for F.
So rather than assuming
that your function
F, that black box, is a linear
function or a neural network
or a random forester or a
Bayesian regression tree,
we're going to
assume that function
takes the form of a nearest
neighbor classifier.
In particular, we'll
say that Y hat of 1,
the function for predicting
the potential outcome Y hat 1,
is given to you by finding the
nearest neighbor of the data
point X according to the
data set of individuals
that received treatment 1,
and same thing for Y hat 0.
And so that then allows
us to actually prove
some properties of matching.
So for example, if
you remember from--
I think I mentioned
in Tuesday's lecture
that this covariate
adjustment approach,
under the assumptions of overlap
and under the assumptions
of no hidden confounding,
and that your function
family for potential outcome
is sufficiently rich that you
can actually fit the
underlying model,
then you're going to
get correct estimates
of your conditional
average treatment effect.
Now, one can show that a nearest
neighbor algorithm is not,
generally, a
consistent algorithm.
And what that means
is that, if you
have a small number
of samples, you're
going to be getting
biased estimate.
Your function F might, in
general, be a biased estimate.
Now, we can conclude
from that, that if we
were to use one nearest
neighbor matching
for inferring average treatment
effect, that in general,
it could give us
a biased estimate
of the average treatment effect.
However, in the limit
of infinite data,
one nearest neighbor
algorithms are
guaranteed to be able to fit
the underlying function family.
That is to say,
that bias goes to 0
in the limit of a
large amount of data,
and thus, we can immediately
draw from that literature
and causal inference--
sorry, from that literature
and machine learning to
obtain theoretical results
for matching for
causal inference.
And so that's all I want
to say about matching
and its connection to
covariate adjustment.
And really, the
punchline is, think
about matching just as another
type of covariate adjustment,
one which uses a nearest
neighbor function family,
and thus should be compared
to other approaches
to covariate adjustments, such
as, for example, using machine
learning algorithms that are
designed to be interpretable.
So the last part
of this lecture is
going to be introducing a
second approach for inferring
average treatment effect that
is known as the propensity score
method, and this is
going to be a real shift.
It's going to be a
different estimator
from the covariate adjustment.
So as I mentioned, it's going
to be used for estimating
average treatment effect.
In problem set 4,
you're going to see
how you can use the
same sorts of techniques
I'll tell you about
now for also estimating
conditional average
treatment effect,
but that won't be obvious
just from today's lecture.
So the key intuition for
propensity score method
is to think back to what
would have happened if you
had a randomized control trial.
In a randomized control
trial, again, you
get choice over what treatment
to give each individual,
so you might imagine
flipping a coin.
If it's heads, giving
them treatment 1.
If it's tails, giving
them treatment 0.
So given data from a
randomized control trial,
then there's a really
simple estimator shown here
for the average
treatment effect.
You just sum up the values
of Y for the individuals
that receive treatment
1, divided by n1,
which is the number
of individuals
that received treatment 1.
So this is the average
outcome for all people who
got treatment 1, and
you just subtract
from that the average outcome
for all individuals who
received treatment 0.
And that can be easily shown
to be an unbiased estimator
of the average
treatment effect had
your data come from a
randomized controlled trial.
So the key idea of a
propensity score method
is to turn an observational
study into something
that looks like a randomized
control trial via re-weighting
of the data points.
So here's the picture I
want you to have in mind.
Again, here, I am not
showing you outcomes.
I'm just showing
you the features X--
that's what the
data points are--
and the treatments that
were given to them, the Ts.
And the Ts, in this
case, are being
denoted by the color of the
dots, so red is T equals 1.
Blue is T equals 0.
And my apologies in advance
for anyone who's color blind.
So the key challenge
when working
with observational
study is that there
might be a bias in terms of who
receives treatment 0 versus who
receives treatment 1.
If this was a randomized
control trial,
then you would expect to
see the reds and the blues
all intermixed equally
with one another,
but as you can see
here, in this data set,
there are very many
more people who
received-- very more young
people who received treatment
0 than received treatment 1.
Said differently, if you look
at the distribution over X
conditioned on T
equals 0 in the data,
it's different from
the distribution
over X conditioned on the
people who receive treatment 1.
So what the propensity score
method is going to do is
it's going to recognize that
there is a difference between
these two distributions, and
it's going to re-weight data
points so that, in aggregate, it
looks like, in any one region--
so for example, imagine
looking at this region--
that there's roughly
the same number
of red and blue data points.
Where if you think about blowing
up this red data point-- here,
I've made it very
big-- you can think
about it being many,
many red data points
of the corresponding weight.
You look over here, see
again roughly the same amount
of red and blue mass as well.
So if we can find some way
to increase or decrease
the weight associated with
each data point such that,
now, it looks like the
two distributions, those
who received treatment 1 and
those who received treatment 0,
look like they came
from-- look like now they
have the same
weighted distribution,
then we're going
to be in business.
So we're going to search
for those weights, w,
that have that property.
So to do that, we
need to introduce
one new concept, which is
known as the propensity score.
The propensity score is given
to you by the probability
that T equals 1
given X. Here, again,
we're going to use
machine learning.
Whereas in covariate
adjustment, we
used machine learning to predict
Y conditioned on X comma T--
that's what covariate
adjustment did--
here, we're going to be
ignoring Y altogether.
We're just going
to take X's input,
and we're going to
be predicting T.
So you can imagine using
logistic regression, given
your covariates, to predict
which treatment any given data
point came from.
Here, you're using the
full data set, of course,
to make that
prediction, so we're
looking at both data
points where T equals 1
and T equals 0.
T is your label for this.
Then what we're
going to do is given,
that learned propensity score--
so we take your data set.
You, first, learn
the propensity score.
Then we're going to re-weight
the data points according
to the inverse of
the propensity score.
And you might ask,
this looks familiar.
This whole notion of
re-weighting data points,
this whole notion of trying
to figure out which, quote,
unquote, "data set" a
data point came from,
the data set of individuals who
receive treatment 1 or the data
set of individuals who
receive treatment 0--
that sounds really familiar.
And it's because it's exactly
what you saw in lecture 10,
when we talked about
data set shift.
In fact, this whole
entire method,
as you'll develop
in problem set 4,
is a special case of learning
under data set shift.
So here, now, is the
propensity score algorithm.
We take our data set, which
have samples of X, T, and Y
where Y, of course, tells
you the potential outcome
corresponding to
the treatment T.
We're going to use any
machine learning method
in order to estimate
this model that
can give you a probability
of treatment given X.
Now, critically, we need
a probability for this.
We're not trying to
do classification.
We need an actual probability,
and so if you remember back
to previous lectures where
we spoke about calibration,
about the ability to accurately
predict probabilities,
that is going to be
really important here.
And so for example, if you were
to use a deep neural network
in order to estimate
the propensity scores,
deep networks are well known
to not be well calibrated.
And so one would have to use
one of a number of new methods
that have been
recently developed
to make the outputs of
deep learning calibrated
in order to use this
type of technique.
So after finishing
step 1, now that you
have a model that can allow
you to estimate the propensity
score for every
data point X, we now
can take those and estimate
your average treatment effect
with the following formula.
It's 1 over n of the sum
over the data points, where
the data points corresponding
to the treatment 1 of Yi--
that part is
identical to before.
But what you see now is
we're going to divide it
by the propensity score,
and so this denominator,
that's the new piece here.
That's the inverse of
the propensity score
is precisely the weighting that
we were referring to earlier,
and the same thing happens
over here for Ti equals 0.
Now, let's try to get some
intuition about this formula,
and I like trying
to get intuition
by looking at a special case.
So the simplest special case
that we might be familiar with
is that of a randomized
control trial, where
because you're flipping a coin,
and each data point either
gets treatment 0 or treatment
1, then the propensity
score is precisely,
deterministically equal to 5.
So let's take this now.
No machine learning done here.
Let's just plug it in to see if
we get back the formula that I
showed you earlier
for the estimate
of the average treatment effect
in a randomized control trial.
So we plug that in over there.
This now becomes 0.5, and
plug that in over here.
This also becomes 0.5.
And then what we're
going to do is we're just
going to take that 0.5.
We're going to bring that out,
and this is going to become a 2
over here, and
same, a 2 over here.
And you get to the
following formula, which
is-- if you were to compare to
the formula from a few slides
ago, it's almost identical,
except that a few slides
ago over here, I had 1 over n1,
and over here, I had 1 over n0.
Now, these two are two different
estimators for the same thing,
and the reason why you can
say they're the same thing
is that, in a randomized
control trial,
the number of individuals
that receive treatment 1
is, on average, n over 2.
Similarly, the number of
individuals receiving treatment
0 are, on average, n over 2.
So if you were to--
that n over 2 cancels
out with this 2 over n
is what gets you a
correct estimator.
So this is a slightly
different estimator,
but nearly identical to the
one that I showed you earlier,
and by this argument, is
a consistent estimator
of the average treatment effect
in a randomized control trial.
So any questions before I try
to derive this formula for you?
So one student asks,
so the propensity score
is the, quote,
unquote, "bias" of how
likely people are assigned
to T equals 1 or T equals 0?
Yes, that's exactly right.
So if you were to imagine
taking an individual where
this probability
for that individual
is, let's say,
very close to 1, it
means that there are very
few other people in the data
set who receive treatment 1.
They're a red data point in
a sea of blue data points.
And by dividing by
that, we're going
to be trying to remove that
bias, and that's exactly right.
Thank you for that question.
Are there other questions?
I really appreciate the
questions via the chat window,
so thank you.
So let's now try to
derive this formula.
Recall the definition of
average treatment effect,
and for those who are
paying very close attention,
you might notice that I removed
the expectation over Y1.
And for this derivation
that I'm going to give you,
I'm going to suppose--
I'm going to assume that a
potential outcomes are all
deterministic because it
makes the math easier,
but is without
loss of generality.
So the average
treatment effect is
the expectation, with
respect to all individuals,
of the potential outcome
Y1 minus the expectation
with respect to all individuals
of the potential outcome Y0.
So this term over here is going
to be our estimate of that,
and this term over here is
going to be our estimate
of this expectation.
So naively, if you were to
just take the observed data,
it would allow you to compute--
if you, for example, just
averaged the values of Y
for the individual who
received treatment 1,
that would give you this
expectation that I'm
showing on the bottom here.
I want you to compare
that to the one that's
actually needed in the
average treatment effect.
Whereas over here, it's an
expectation with respect
to individuals that received
treatment 1, up here,
this was an expectation with
respect to all individuals.
But the thing inside
the expectation
is exactly identical,
and that's the key point
that we're going
to work with, which
is that we want an
expectation with respect
to a different distribution than
the one that we actually have.
And again, this
should ring bells,
because this sounds
very, very familiar
to the data set shift
story that we talked
about a few lectures ago.
So I'm going to show you how
to derive an estimator for just
this first term, and the
second term is obviously
going to be identical.
So let's start out
with the following.
We know that p of X
given T times p of T
is equal to p of X
times p of T given X.
So what I've just done here
is use two different formulas
for a joint distribution,
and then I've
divided by p of T
given X in order
to get the formula that I
showed you a second ago.
I'm not going to
attempt to erase that.
I'll leave it up there.
So the next thing we're going
to do is we're going to say,
if we were to compute an
expectation with respect
to p of X given T equals 1,
and if we were to now take
the value that we observe, Y1,
which we can get observations
for all the individuals
who received treatment 1,
and if we were to re-weight
this observation by this ratio,
where remember,
this ratio showed up
in the previous bullet point,
then what I'm going to show you
in just a moment is that
this is equal to the quantity
that we actually wanted.
Well, why is that?
Well, if you expand
this expectation,
this expectation is an
integral with respect
to p of X conditioned
on T equals 1 times
the thing inside the brackets,
and because we know that p of--
because we know from up here
that p of X conditioned on T
equals 1 times p of T
equals 1 divided by p of T
equals 1 conditioned on
X is equal to p of X,
this whole thing
is just going to be
equal to an integral of p of
X times Y1, which is precisely
the definition of
expectation that we want.
So this was a very
simple derivation
to show you that the
re-weighting gets you
what you need.
Now, we can estimate this
expectation empirically
as follows, the
estimate that we're
going to now sum
over all data points
that received treatment 1.
We're going to take
an average, so we're
dividing by the
number of data points
that received treatment 1.
For p of T equals
1, we're just going
to use the empirical estimate
of how many individuals received
treatment 1 in the
data set divided
by the total number of
individuals in the data set.
That's n1 divided by n.
And for the denominator, p of
T equals 1 conditioned on X,
we just plug in, now, the
propensity score, which
we had previously estimated.
And we're done.
And so that, now,
is our estimate
for the first term in the
average treatment effect,
and you can do that now
loosely for Ti equals 0.
And I've shown
you the full proof
of why this is an unbiased
estimator for average treatment
effect.
So I'm going to be concluding
now, in the next few minutes.
First, I just wanted to
comment on what we just saw.
So we saw a different way to
estimate the average treatment
effect, which only required
estimating the propensity
score.
In particular, we never
had to use a model
to predict Y in this
approach for estimating
the average treatment
effect, and that's
a good thing and a bad thing.
It's a good thing
because, if you
had errors in
estimating your model y,
as I showed you in the very
beginning of today's lecture,
that could have
a very big impact
on your estimate of the
average treatment effect.
And so that doesn't
show up here.
On the other hand, this
has its own disadvantages.
So for example, the propensity
score is going to be really,
really affected by
lack of overlap,
because when you
have lack of overlap,
it means there's some data
points where the propensity
score is very close to
0 or very close to 1.
And that really leads
to very large variance
in your estimators.
And a very common
trick which is used
to try to address
that concern is
known as clipping, where you
simply clip the propensity
scores so that they're always
bounding away from 0 and 1.
But that's really
just a heuristic,
and it can, of course, then
lead to biased estimates
of the average treatment effect.
So there's a whole family of
causal inference algorithms
that attempt to use ideas
from both covariate adjustment
and inverse
propensity weighting.
For example, there's
a method called
doubly robust
estimators, and we'll
try to provide a citation for
those estimators in the Scribe
notes.
And these doubly
robust estimators
are a different family of
estimators that actually bring
in both of these
techniques together,
and they have a
really nice property,
which is that if either
one of them fail,
you still get valid estimates
of average treatment effect.
I'm going to skip this and just
jump to the summary now, which
is that we've presented
two different approaches
for causal inference
from observational data--
covariate adjustment and
propensity score based methods.
And both of these,
I need to stress,
are only going to
give you valid results
under the assumptions
we outlined
in the previous lecture--
for example, that your
causal graph is correct;
critically, that there's no
unobserved confounding; and
second, that you have overlap
between your two treatment
classes.
And third, if you're using
a non-parametric regression
approach, overlap is
extremely important,
because without
overlap, your model's
undefined in regions of space.
And thus, as a result,
you have no way
of verifying if your
extrapolations are correct,
and so one has to use trust
in the model, which is not
something we really like.
And in propensity score methods,
overlap is very important
because if you don't have that,
you get inverse propensity
scores that are either--
which are infinite and lead
to extremely high variance
estimators.
So in the end of this
slide, which are already
posted online, I
include some references
that I strongly encourage
folks to follow up on.
First references to two
recent workshops that
have been held in the machine
learning community so that you
can get a sense of what the
latest and greatest in terms
of research in
causal inference are,
two different books
on causal inference
that you can download
for free from MIT,
and finally, some
papers that I think
are really interesting,
particularly of interest,
potentially, to course projects.
So we are at time now.
I will hang around for a
few minutes after lecture,
as I would normally.
But I'm going to stop the
recording of the lecture.